what's great about the Android runtime
is that most of the stress of memory
reclamation is done for you
the system will track what you're doing
and when it sees that an object is in
need anymore
it will free it on your behalf now while
this is great for your general health
and blood pressure this doesn't exclude
performance problems from happening here
my name's Colt McAnlis and it's a good
idea for you to know
what types a performance Paul's work
under the hood of your managed memory
environment as see when the amount of
memory you have allocated reaches an
upper limit
a garbage collection event we kicked off
to free any resources that might not be
needed any longer
freeing up space for future allocations
and depending on what runtime using a GC
event can stop application code from
executing
in order to properly clean up any
resources that are being used anymore
now I G seas are a common and natural
part of the management environment
and the garbage collection events in
Android har really pretty fast
performance problems here come from the
fact that misusing the memory in your
application
can cause a cascade of these events to
kick off that's heating up your free
time
anytime your frame drips about the 16 no
second barrier
users are going to start to notice so
any your code that
forces allocated memory to spike above
this threshold
can cause problems memory leaks are one
such example
basically your code allocate memory for
a large number objects and never freeze
that memory
over time these objects act as a large
immovable block a memory
forcing the referee application to
operate in what's left up the heat
member can also become tighter
allocating and freeing a large amount of
objects in a short period of time
saturating your heat with temporary
objects and again kicking off a GC
as a result for example allocating new
objects in the middle the nested loops
or in the on
draw functions are your views now the
solution here is pretty simple:
picture code but in order to do that you
need to know where exactly things are
going wrong
for chilling entrance to do you have
some great tools to help with this
firstly using memory monitor tool will
give you a sense of how your memory
allocations are working
over the lifetime of your application
every time you see a dip in the
allocated memory
that see a GC event occurring lots of
dips in a really short time frame
signals a huge problem
long and for more detailed look at what
portions have your coat or specifically
allocating memory
you can use the allocation tracker tab
in Android studio or
use the Heat have an Android studio to
see if there's a spike in a certain type
of object
or if that object-type isn't being freed
when it should be
well those are really bad things so for
every garbage collection event that you
can avoid
your app has more time per frame to do
interesting things which allow you to
create a smooth beautiful
user experience which is why I need to
check out the rest at the tip that
Android performance patterns and don't
forget to join our Google+ community to
get more
in the trenches advice from other
developers so as always keep calm
profile your code to remember perhaps